Oh does it look like I'm kind of trying
as I'm definitely Stuart's my pants
[ __ ] no hi my name is grace helping
feed don't no no you know your life it's
different now
so the Grammys happened over the weekend
I did not see them because I was in Las
Vegas seeing the Backstreet Boys who I
just found out also attended the Grammys
didn't know they were Wizards but did
learn that they are amazing performers
guys if you have a chance go check out
their residency nuts on but I'd make
their spawn that one took an unexpected
turn okay let's get into this there's a
ton of photos a ton of people were there
a ton of people that I don't recognize
and I will also likely forget a ton of
people that you want me to talk about so
let's just jump right into this shall we
rhetorical question if anyone said yes
or no out loud well watching this a box
of crayons became a bunch of valet
drivers let's take the dressing up is
like a punk edits version of devon Sawa
in his heyday
even though devon Sawa it might be
having a second heyday his Instagram is
pretty confusingly great just throwing
that out there obviously looking at a
photo BTS leads to me recommending devon
Sawa Instagram so off to a good start
you Backstreet Boys how did what how did
you get there and you all look clean and
nice and great I'm holding on to a
conspiracy theory that AJ has two glass
eyes because he wears sunglasses all the
time maybe just got sensitive eyes or
it's fashion you look great also a great
show on Saturday cuz I can hear that
when I talk at their photo on my own
laptop cute already beat what is
happening what what is she being birth
it looks like very gaudy vagina what is
this why is what I like it it's
confusing this looks like cardi B it's
being pushed out of the cooter of a
woman in her 70s on the Upper East Side
how do you walk in this use hop this is
like a very elegant [ __ ] inspired
potato sack race skew Fantasia Barrino
whoa architecture in the
fashion seems like a big theme this year
what is this it seems like a Death Eater
was eating you at a white party and you
were like oh wait okay I go to the
grandmas you can come with I guess but
like don't just stay there we'll get
back to you swallowing me whole when the
show is done cute
Ricky Martin and Matteo Martin oh my
gosh this is adorable tail Martin looks
like tiny Tom Cruise is that actually
Tom Cruise and we're all mistaking it
for Ricky Martin son Ricky Martin ha I
had a huge crush on Ricky Martin in high
school I was living my vida loca back in
those days so I listened to the lyrics
of livin la vida loca recently they are
questionable listen for yourself see
what you some mice but dem some ice
look it's strange to my soul okay cute
st. Vincent oh I will pray at the Church
of latter-day Saint Vincent it looks
like you took the full drapes from a
room at the Four Seasons and made it
fashion I like this a lot Grammys are
fun because you can do [ __ ] like this
and it's cool it's like you've created a
very fashionable cut for your legs cute
Kylie Jenner
okay sure why not I don't know what the
[ __ ] this is but it's cool also those
clubs don't you feel a little
claustrophobic though but you can murder
someone tonight and no one would ever
know except you running away it will be
a little obvious it's like a big roll of
bubble gum tape decided the tables have
turned [ __ ] I know we chew you up and
spit you out
yeah post Malone he looks happy to be
posing like a six year old that's going
to see the Easter Bunny at a suburban
mall I this is great this is a
flamboyant cowboy meet someone that fell
asleep at a frat party before everyone
else did shanthi wow this looks like
very high fashion diary very cool very
ice dancer up top and then like a
weighted blanket that you were sleeping
on your couch at home
it's stuck around your waist on the way
out the door and you just you went with
it comforting JLo whoa what is this geo
dream catchers on your tits this is like
Westworld meets the Met Gala also the
Hat is a fun device so that no one can
get to your face so you could put chips
and salsa all around the top of that hat
and no one would know you guys so many
snacks up
no no ain't [ __ ] idea she's a genius
kid Moo Anna Kendrick oh you look like a
[Music]
one of those little puppies in Beverly
Hills that the women that have too much
time and money
get them dyed pink that's a compliment
those are very cute animals and this is
much more humane that you're cute Lady
gaga
I was didn't recognize her what is
different she looks fantastic I love
this she looks like a delicious chewy
sea chicken wing that I had leftover at
Chili's and had to get wrapped up in
tinfoil and take home with me to eat
drunkenly later not in front of my
friends cute Katy Perry what's happening
so delighted to see you I hope it's
comfortable I want to see you walk in
this I feel like you can only walk like
this and I like the half-sister of
Gritti
you know the Philly Phanatic and gritty
the mascots their bellies go like that
that they bump with if gritty [ __ ]
Charlize Theron this might be the
lovechild dude
Dolly Parton oh my god yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah Molly Parton is doing the red dress
dancing lady emoji as cosplay and I'm
here for it I can't believe you're
wearing heels that high
god bless your beautiful song you know
Tracee Ellis Ross this looks fantastic
she always looks absolutely incredible
this color is amazing you guys snake
wrapped around you your hair is [ __ ]
gorgeous Jesus you look like a
high-fashion real estate agent and I'll
buy every condo you show me you do Lipa
whoa very mature
yes it's very elegant very Vanna White
like to solve the puzzle please uh Jim
bebe Rexha ooh red velvet cake topper
cute janelle monae again another person
that can wear absolutely anything this
looks great this is like a prince
charming from Cinderella and like old
school Lady gaga
[ __ ] this would be maybe the results you
a lot of talking about people and things
[ __ ] that's the only way I know how
to assess fashion I'm sorry Miley Cyrus
Oh what oh I own your hands like that
are they in pockets or were you actually
a dolt that like Oh which doctor only
brought half your life this is pretty
like Tatum for the Grammys it says if
you took like Liam suit jacket and then
put some capri pants with that q Kacey
Musgraves oh this is cool this is light
and fun an area and also but the top
makes me nervous said it first strong
gusts of wind rolls through you might be
tipped off to some Tatas still very
whimsical very pretty very mosquito
nutmeats doily meets fashion you Lilly
Singh oh my god that you look stunning
look at you getting a little sexy and
scandalous up top and over a power
business boss on the bottom I like that
combo good mix lots of balance cute okay
those are all the pictures that I pulled
that's it for my Grammys red carpet
review let me know who you guys loved
and who you you know had alternate
feelings for in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe to this
YouTube channel I'm putting out content
turn on the bail notifications and all
that fun stuff and don't forget that
every Monday my podcast not too deep
it's available wherever you listen to
podcast and every Wednesday May
Mirandized podcast this might get weird
is available for your beautiful grubby
wonderful ears other than that I don't
know Heidi Klum is there thank God I've
missed her so much oh she's always at
the Grammys and looks she looks ahh this
is what it looks like when doves cry it
looks a little bit like a dove got
caught in a leaf blower but it wasn't
gonna stop it from attending the Grammys
cute